[Musique]
c'est au palais de la source que série
melchior président du département a
organisé une conférence de presse
concernant la recentralisation du rsa
la somme qui nous est donnée par l'état
n'est pas suffisant pour couvrir tout ce
que l'on donne est donc nous avons dû à
l'état ou bien vous nous donner la
totalité ou alors vous reprenez à votre
charge cette dépense est bien de l'état
15 ans tombe à 15 est aujourd'hui on
arrive donc au bout de nos peines l'état
le président la république et le
populisme ont accepté à travers a visité
deux ministres étaient là on a eu la
réponse l'état et a beaucoup à la
recentralisation du rsa cela fait une
dizaine d'années que le département
demande à l'état de récupérer la gestion
et le financement du rsa à la réunion 97
milles personnes sont bénéficiaires du
rsa soit environ 225 mille personnes
concernées et le sujet je veux vous dire
c'est de pouvoir accompagner ces
personnes lutter contre la précarité
travailler pour que chacun puisse
essayer de trouver une activité
c'est pour ça que quand on dit à l'état
de reprendre une recentralisation
c'est qu'on veut accompagner ces
familles dans leurs difficultés quoi
plus d'emplois d'activité et best buy
faut les moyens
le président du département espère que
le changement sera effectif au 1er
janvier 2020
[Musique]